a young friend of mine a few weeks ago
was telling me about getting his wisdom
teeth pulled and the pain that you know
was resulting from that
and it's kind of a big deal it's kind of
a rite of passage for
for many of us sometimes it happens in
your teens sometimes
in your early 20s it usually doesn't go
on too long
some people never get their wisdom teeth
pulled if you've got enough room for
them in the in the back
but many of us in fact do and actually
some some people they have to get them
hold because otherwise
their mouth would be completely screwed
up
uh if if that didn't happen
and that reminded me of my own
rather grisly and gruesome experience
with getting
my wisdom teeth pulled which i'm going
to tell you about
here but i want to give a little bit of
a warning
ahead of time if you're the kind of
person who is
you know turned off or disgusted
or made anxious by hearing about pain
and suffering and medical matters then
this video might not be for you
if on the other hand you want to hear
the story
i'm going to tell it right now and the
story begins with
not getting my wisdom teeth pulled when
they really should have been
done i was in the united states army
over in germany
and this was you know the late 80s early
90s
and i was in a combat engineer unit
because that's what i was i was in the
16th engineers
and you know during peace time in that
era
there was this tendency to you know
cut costs as much as possible so you
know we were
technically allowed to go on sick call
if we needed you know one of the
benefits of being in the military
is you're supposed to have at least
decent and and free
health care but you have to go on sick
call
in order to use that right they don't
just like
let you walk into an office everything
has to be approved and
i couldn't get on sick call for
you know most things when i was sick and
neither could most of my fellow soldiers
for example it took me a month of you
know enduring
five mile runs every morning with with
terrible pain in my hip
and just sort of toughing it out before
um you know seeing me limping around
finally one of one of uh the people in
charge
let me go on sick call and then going to
sick call meant that a medic looked at
me and said oh you got bursitis in your
hip here's some
you know icy hot put it on on that once
a night
that's it you're not going to check
anything yeah that was
that was it and i
you know i was i was only born with
three wisdom teeth they're the molars in
the very back of your mouth
and if you only have one tooth on one
side as it's coming out
there's a tendency for the tooth to just
keep going and going and going so i
actually have a big enough
mouth that i could probably have those
wisdom teeth in the back of my
jaw but only having one on one side
meant that the other one kept growing
and growing and eventually started
cutting into my gum
and it wasn't you know terrible but it
wasn't
fun either it wasn't something that you
just didn't notice
and so i eventually you know got to go
on sick call for it and
inter interestingly enough um the the
army people who looked at me they're
like
we're not going to do anything about
this for for the time being we'll just
we'll just
keep monitoring it and i was like my
tooth
and they're like we've decided and so
then i i got out of the army
and it was you know continuing to bother
me but not you know
terribly and um
you know it started getting worse and
started getting worse by this time i was
up in college at lakeland college
and uh living if i remember right in in
one of the dorms and i had a girlfriend
who was who was local
in sheboygan actually fiance at the time
and so i was on my mom's insurance and i
didn't use it very often i mean if i got
like a cold or something i didn't go to
the doctor for that
i wasn't like breaking bones or anything
although i do remember actually
while i was working down here in
waukesha
i gave myself a nasty scar
breaking boxes one of them turned out to
have a
steel bar in it when i was working at
shakey's pizza
or no ponderosa that's right because
they took me to the waukesha hospital
in any case i didn't go to the hospital
very very much and i i
you know i was on my mom's insurance
plan
she had an hmo which was basically
a 1980s 1990s cost cutting measure
you could only go to certain hospitals
certain doctors
only certain things were covered you had
to pay on top of that it was like one of
the the beginning of the
progressive suckiness of american
healthcare the hmo
and so um we scheduled you know an
appointment
for me to go down to the milwaukee area
and
um you know get my my wisdom teeth taken
care of
and so i think there must have been an
initial time with with a dentist
and then we we scheduled me for the
actual
operation and i had had a lot of friends
who'd had their wisdom teeth taken out
generally they were put under um
they're sedated they were put under
anesthetic they had like a gas and you'd
fall asleep and then
you'd wake up and your mouth would feel
like somebody had you know punched you
and you know um carved into your jaw and
stuff like that but
you didn't actually you weren't
conscious
for the operation while they were
digging around
so i get there and my my fiance had
driven
me down from um college
up in sheboygan and were
at the the doctor's office and i guess
she must have stayed out in the waiting
room or something
by that time my mom had moved to
menominee falls
because i remember the house afterwards
and so i go into the dentist's office
and i'm sitting there in the chair and
they put
the bib on you and all that sort of
stuff and you're laying back
and then the uh must have been like the
nurse or
you know dental assistant you know has
got like a clipboard and they're like
so do you want to be put under for this
and i was like yeah of course and she's
like well
that's going to be 600 extra your
insurance doesn't cover it
and i was like what do you mean and
she's like
you know it's just not covered we'll
give you a local
that's fine but you'll be awake during
the operation
or do you want to pay 600 bucks and then
you'll just wake up
and you know you won't feel great but
you won't have gone through the
trauma of the the operation itself
and i was like well i don't have 600
and this is kind of a surprise to me and
you know i'm like sitting there in the
chair i think probably
being a young you know kind of kind of
macho guy probably figured in
i was like how bad could it be famous
last words
and so i was like okay i i'm i'm just
gonna take the local
and and that'll be fine so they began
and the local meant
shooting my my gums up with you know all
sorts of stuff
and uh that was painful itself already
and i'm like uh
well you know i've had like dental
operations done before like
cavities so how bad could this possibly
be
then the uh the dentist comes in
and he says all right so for the first
part of this
your some of your teeth are really kind
of stuck in there
we're gonna have to cut and he gets out
like a something almost like a scalpel
and by now i'm kind of numb but not
like numb to the pain but not numb to
sensation
and i can feel him like cutting digging
around
in my my jaw and then i hear him say oh
those are really
in there not what you want to hear
what you want to hear is wow they're
almost like falling out
and instead you know he's doing all this
stuff and then
finally he's like okay we're ready to
extract them how you do it you know
and like you know they're doing the
suction thing in my mouth
and you know my of course my my vocal
apparatus
is all messed up because of the the
anesthetic
so then here's where it gets really kind
of gross
i'm even feeling a little queasy
remembering it
he has something like pliers
except of course there's a dentist
pliers right it's it's a little bit
fancier
and he puts it in my mouth and he's like
okay hold on
and he clamps it down on my my wisdom
tooth and he starts
twisting and i can hear the bone
like some i mean the roots the bones
whatever it is that is attaching
that tooth like crackling and i'm not
just like
hearing it i'm feeling it running
through my
jaw and i'm like oh this is gross
you know um and then he's like oh i
can't i can't get enough leverage
your teeth are really in there and he
puts his
foot on my shoulder
so that he can have his hands in there
and he can
pull you know and he can get as much
leverage
as possible and then he's he's twisting
as he's doing and now though the
cracking and the crunching
of the bones and the roots and all that
is is
way louder way stronger it's
reverberating it's basically i've been
turned into
like a tooth socket and that's all
that's my whole world
at that point then bam the tooth comes
out and he like you know jerks back
because you know he's like i said he's
got his foot on my shoulder
so he can use his full muscular strength
to do that well i'm laying back like
this
that's one we go through two more
like that each one requires
some bone cracking some twisting with
the pliers
inside of my mouth and then we're
finally done
and they start you know sucking all the
blood out of my mouth because my mouth
is just like filling up with with blood
you know and they've been doing that as
uh time has gone on
throughout the the entire thing um
but you know it's it's kind of gross
it's it's not it's not
very fun things are actually starting
now to hurt a little bit
and then he says all right so the last
thing we got to do
is uh sew you back up and i'm like
thinking so me back up what the hell
does that mean and
he like looks at me and he's like so you
got some these you know big holes
in your your gum now and i've got this
uh you know it's just like stitching up
a wound we're gonna stitch that up
inside of your mouth
and i'm like oh okay well at least we're
near the end right
and um he does that and i don't really
you know i can i can feel kind of
vaguely things happening
inside of my mouth but you know i'm i'm
numb so
and then it's basically wham bam thank
you ma'am let's get you out of here you
know
you we're we're done with you on to the
next patient
for the day and he said the nurse will
give you some instructions
and they've got my mouth packed with
gauze and uh you know we're in
maybe like the waiting room or something
like that and my fiance comes in
and they gave us a little bit of
paperwork and then they're like okay he
should like you know take it easy
um here's where you can get his
painkillers the prescription
and you know he should rest for the rest
of the day
somebody should like keep track of him
and make sure
he gets enough fluids you know ice is is
is helpful um here's some more gauze you
know to pack in because he's going to
keep bleeding all over the place
so see you later that's that right
and that's where the story should have
ended but the story didn't quite end
there so we get home to my mom's place
and my mom is like oh how did it go and
my fiance and my mom are
chitter-chattering you know they're both
big talkers and i'm kind of out of it
you know
now the painkillers are the the um
anesthetic is starting to wear off
starting to feel some pain
and um you know it's basically like
having the crap beat out of you this
this sort of experience that i went
through and so i remember
laying down on the couch in the living
room with a pillow
and just like dozing off and then
my mom and my fiance they must have told
me that they
were going out nobody's watching me
right and they went out shopping
and now these were two people who like
to shop and they're hanging out together
so they're you know they're gonna go to
brookfield square wherever
and shop for stuff meanwhile
i wake up and my mouth is full of blood
and i'm like choking i'm like what the
hell is going on
obviously i don't say anything um and i
get up and i
like blood just pours out of my mouth
because so much of it is pooled in there
and i go to the bathroom
look in the mirror and i'm like trying
to look inside my mouth
you know and i don't have a flashlight
or anything just the lights from the
thing
to try to figure out what the hell is
going on so i like try to wash my mouth
out with water and it's just blood
you know coming out and so there was a
card about the dentist's office and i
call them up
and you know at first
my you know my mouth is is filling up
with blood i've just had you know these
wisdom teeth cut out
i'm not very articulate and they're like
what are you trying to say sir
and i was like my mouth full of blood
i'm sure they had calls like that all
the time but it also probably was kind
of confusing for them
in retrospect as well and as it turned
out
the stitches on at least one of the
teeth
were not like something went wrong
i don't know if the doctor the dentist
didn't do things quite up to snuff or it
was bad materials or
i was just you know uh you know a
one-off or something like that
in any case like these had come open and
they're like
sir you know you're just gonna have to
like put ice
and and you know keep packing more gauze
in there
and uh basically hope for the best
because you're done for today you know
we're not taking you back
in and you know i'm half
half you know still like
anesthetized and and you know i've had
this this terrible thing
happened to me and i was like oh okay
and plus you know i also
kind of come from you know a time and
a culture where the doctor said
something so you do what the doctor said
they they know best and now we know that
that that's not a good attitude to have
towards doctors or dentists or
whoever else and um
you know i i like switched out the gauze
a couple times because
it would just get soaked with with blood
and eventually it stops and and by the
time
that it stops i you know i'm i'm kind of
weak so i've been like throwing the
gauze on the floor
and i don't know it was it was pretty
late when my fiance and mom came back
they must have left me for
for hours and i'm you know half asleep
and like trying to sit in ways that
where i'm not gonna like you know choke
or cough or anything like that
and they come in and suddenly it's like
oh wow there's there's a crisis here
and i'm like the crisis was hours ago
where the hell were you two oh
shopping you know and uh
you know we get me cleaned up you know
we get some more painkillers in me
i go up to go go to bed and
i think if i remember right i think my
fiance like drove back to sheboygan or
something
and i just stayed there at my mom's
place for like a day or two and then
maybe she drove me back up or my fiance
came back down
you know it's not that long of a drive
from from that
sheboygan area to milwaukee and it took
a while to you know recover
um and then it was the fun part i have
popsicles and ice cream and all that
sort of sort of stuff but
boy did that suck the two things that i
remember the most from it
are that those moments when the when the
dentist had his
foot on my shoulder and was grinding
away
with that pliers in my mouth until the
tooth popped out
and then that that moment of fear
waking up with my mouth full of
something
and like getting up and blood basically
like in a horror movie just like pouring
down
my my chin onto my shirt
onto the floor and being like what the
hell is going on
so uh long story short wisdom teeth
kind of a big deal for some people if
you get the option of being put under
definitely take it don't don't try to
tough it out
and make sure that you get good
follow-up after that
so if you stuck with me through this
whole story hope
it didn't gross you out too much but um
you know i don't tell too many stories
like this uh i think many of us
have quite a few along these lines like
you know this scar here and i got this
thing here
maybe i'll do more of these down the
line about about crazy things that
happen
but there you have it
you